now everybody's been watching swimming
down in Rio and probably the most
recognizable face now after Michael
Phelps is Michele Tafoya because she has
talked to every single swimmer has the
best seat in the house as the poolside
reporter and look Michelle is one of the
best in the business whether it's
football it's basketball or swimming in
the Olympics Michelle is a true
professional I always tell folks you
want to watch the best watch what she
does and watch how she delivers
information Michele Tafoya joins us now
from the real games in a Michelle how
are you doing I want to hire you to do
my next contract that was very very kind
you have crushed it this week and what
is it like standing poolside and getting
the reaction in those great moments like
the Simone Manuel moment that you got
last night I gotta tell you I I left the
arena last night saying to people how
did I get this lucky to get this
assignment at this time in history this
is unreal it's been fantastic and you
know you can't help it you're abroad
we've spent a lot of time from the US
Olympic Trials to their pre Olympic
training camp with the team so we've
gotten to know the swimmers we've got
another coaches and our audience is the
American audience we know that you guys
are out there cheering for these smarts
it's impossible for us not to cheer for
them to this is the Olympics for crying
out loud so when Simone in our meeting
yesterday before that she swam I said
you guys Simone's getting on a podium I
just I know it count on that and um then
when she did that and it I I turned
around and like the guy that's working
with me Larry her he's from USA Swimming
I'm like pounding his shoulder I'm just
so excited I just couldn't stand it it
was so exciting and to have her come
over as emotional she was I'm telling
you those are the moments you live for
in this role Kevin you know that is it's
you live for that moment to be able to
have an interchange with someone who's
just had a life changing experience
arian so she's in the history books I
you know we've been talking all day
about sports moments that brought a tear
to your eye are made you cry did you get
have you gotten a little teary-eyed at
some of these moments because it's hard
to divorce yourself from the greatness
and the emotion of the moment especially
so close to it yeah I think a couple of
times where I fought it our metal stands
I think seeing seeing Simone last night
there was a time when i interviewed
michael one morning and we showed him
the video of himself climbing up to kiss
his son after he had won the 200 fly and
he started to cry in the interview and
it's kind of choked me up a little bit
it is a challenge it's it's this this
thing the the stuff going on here is the
feelings are palpable you know it's not
just water and humidity in there it's
there's an energy in there that it's
it's stunning I I just got to tell you
I'm having the time of my life has
Michael Phelps upped his legacy and now
Ryan Lochte said he's going to come back
we just talked to him he said he hopes
will come back oh he thinks Phelps will
come back you know I'd I personally I
don't now there's a lot of debate about
that around here but Michaels got a
gazillion opportunities in problem he
has worked so hard to get to this place
to get the revenge he wanted as he put
it to get back to being the best I'm not
sure that he's going to want to do that
again he's got a child now he's about to
get married he's got a lot of business
interests I could actually see him I've
seen him on the pool deck coaching his
teammates coaching him up and talking
about times in all this I don't know
what is next for Michael but I don't
think he's the kind of guy that would
want to come back and only swim to swims
in Olympics just to keep swimming I I
mean this is going to be the pinnacle
for him if this is going to be etched in
the swimming annals forever of the
Olympic animals forever I don't know
that you want to risk painting that by
trying to come back and just just for
the sake of coming back that
yep could he do it he probably could but
he's been talking a lot off-camera about
how exhausted he is and so I'm just not
sure he's going to be able to muster it
in four years we're gonna want to well
you know Michelle you've covered so many
great athletes you know it's so hard for
them to walk away I mean you you cover
Michael Guerin extensively and Michael
couldn't walk away he had to come back
yet have that last stint with the wizard
so I'm just curious how hard will it be
for him to UM walk away hey best moment
for you you know what I think it had
their couple Michael after the 200 fly
it just says it's a rare opportunity to
get an interview that is so honest and
so I mean that was the story of the
games up until then it was remarkable
the way he swam and then some no
questions to mall just the significance
of it I know that someday she wants it
to be just a normal thing that
african-american swimmers are part of
the you know part of the the landscape
here but at this moment in time it's
significant we knew it the second it
happened and to watch her be so
emotional getting out of the pool all of
it it was just it was so compelling and
I to share in that was ridiculous I I
pinch myself now and you did such a
great job with that interview um I know
you're in real but you still have
football to get ready for have you
watched any of the preseason football no
I haven't seen anything I'm a little
panicky I'm getting all the emails about
okay here's stuff for our first
preseason game and here's the back to
football memo and this and I'm like oh
oh my gosh I have a lot to do but um you
know what when I get home next week i'm
just gonna submerge myself and we'll
figure it out if you need any updates
mclovin is here he is staying on top of
the NFL world he'll call you later and
he'll update you on everything I may
need to have an extensive conversation
with mclovin when I get back in the face
Michelle I will come over we'll watch
some games and tape will be great
Michelle thank you for taking the time
you've done a amazing job down in Rio
you've really brought us into those
moments those great moments right after
people have gotten out of the pool but
you know what your pro and that's what
you do and so thank you for being a
professor you're really you're too kind
you're too kind i appreciate you having
me on the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience